seit jahren wird davor gewarnt und in
diesem sommer scheint es offensichtlich
so weit zu sein die tropenkrankheit mit
dem namen west nil virus hat wohl den
sprung über die alpen geschafft in den
letzten wochen hat das virus märz 800
menschen in südeuropa befallen und mehr
als 70 von ihnen getötet
derzeit untersuchen noch experten und
expertinnen mücken um genau diesen
verdacht zu erhärten
wie den west nil viren wohl die
ausbreitung gelangen und wie gefährlich
sie wirklich sind erfahrt ihr jetzt paar
klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich neue science videos abonniert
den channel sehr gerne herzlich
willkommen das virus wurde 1937 erstmals
in uganda entdeckt seit jahren kursieren
die viren bereits südlich der alpen in
diesem jahr haben sie beispielsweise in
kroatien und südfrankreich neue gebiete
erobert verfliegen handfeste nachweise
vor auch in den usa ist das virus
mittlerweile verbreitet und dass es nach
deutschland kommt war wohl nur eine
frage der zeit der außergewöhnlich warme
sommer mit der lang anhaltenden hitze
hat wohl seinen teil dazu beigetragen
dass sich der erreger in dieser saison
so massiv ausbreiten konnten
als überträger der viren kommen einige
heimische arten von mücken in frage und
diese haben in diesem jahr nicht nur
besonders früh angefangen blut zu saugen
sondern auch besonders viele europäer
gefallen
den hinweis darauf dass sich das virus
auch in deutschland ausbreitet kommt aus
halle an der saale dort war ein waldkauz
gestorben weil er eben genau diesen
virus erlag expertenteams wollen jetzt
natürlich ganz genau wissen woher der
erreger kann der die eule getötet hat
mücken fallen wurden aufgestellt und die
gefangenen blutsauger in einem labor des
friedrich loeffler instituts untersucht
insgesamt gibt es jetzt bundesweit drei
nachweise von west nil fieber bei vögeln
zwei davon in sachsen anhalt beunruhigt
sind die solchen teams weil der erreger
auch auf menschen übertragbar ist und
eben bisher in deutschland nicht
heimisch war laut robert koch institut
gibt es bisher aber keine informationen
über menschliche erkrankungsfälle an
west nil fieber in dieser region das
könnte aber auch an mangelnden
untersuchungen liegen beim menschen
führt die tropenkrankheit jedenfalls zu
erbrechen kopfschmerzen und fieber in
den meisten fällen fühlt sie sich also
die eine gewinn
ähnliche sommergrippe nach angaben der
weltgesundheitsorganisation vero gibt es
bei nur einem von 150 infizierten
schwere komplikationen diese können dann
aber auch zum tod führen doch klar ist
auch frühere ausbrüche können nicht
wirklich zum vergleich dient dazu
christina koch vom robert-koch-institut
das west nil virus ist stark unter
diagnostiziert heißt also im klartext
weil die symptome der tropenkrankheit
denen der sommergrippe so ähnlich sind
kommen viele ärzte teams gar nicht
darauf nach diesen erregern zu suchen
das passiert meist erst wenn besonders
viele vögel oder tiere in der region an
den virus verändern und so ein
anfangsverdacht gegeben ist bisher gibt
es weder impfungen noch medikamente die
helfen können als schutz gibt es
chemischen abwehrmittel oder eben lange
kleidung die nackte haut verdeckt die
meisten der mückenarten die das west nil
virus übertragen stechen übrigens nicht
nur in der dunkelheit sondern den ganzen
tag über
fest steht aber die ansteckung läuft
wohl über mücken und nicht durch den
kontakt mit flügeln die infizierte
mücken sind höchstwahrscheinlich mit
lastwagen oder mit güterzügen mit nach
deutschland eingeschleppt worden jetzt
wird darüber diskutiert ob blutspenden
dienste auch auf dieses virus testen
sollen dieses bislang nämlich nicht in
allen bundesländern der fall und wenn
ihr zu diesem und zu anderen themen kein
video mehr verpassen wollt dann habe ich
am ende des videos antrieb für euch
jetzt aber unser hochgestecktes ziel
keine werbung mehr auf gigs und wir
haben ja schon angefangen immer mehr
videos sind werbefrei dank eurer hilfe
immer wenn wir entsprechen viele kanal
mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir
die werbung vor einem video abwertet
also mitglied hier unter dem video
draufklicken oder auf den link in der
video beschreibung klicken und ihr
bekommt noch exklusive extra videos live
streams und noch ein paar weitere
privilegierung für einen
und jetzt der trick wenn er immer
garantiert über aktuelle videos
informiert werden wollt dann endet mich
bei whatsapp nur da bekommt er das
aktuelle video deutlich vor allen
anderen von mir persönlich auf euer
handy einfach hier draufklicken und
darunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken erfolglosen von viren
werden so gnadenlosen kindern bis dann
bleibt kann